este vídeo ha sido posible gracias al
surf shark vpn luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
mirarlo en la wikipedia sabrías decirme
cuál es la divisa oficial en el salvador
pues la moneda de este país es el dólar
de eeuu habéis oído bien desde el año
2001 el dólar estadounidense es la
moneda de curso legal en el salvador
[Música]
sin embargo mis queridos amigos de
visual política a partir del próximo mes
de septiembre de 2021 el salvador tendrá
oficialmente dos monedas el dólar y
atención el bitcoin porque si el
salvador acaba de aprobar el bitcoin
como moneda de curso legal y diréis pero
esto qué significa exactamente pues que
se pueden pagar impuestos en bitcoin y
que todos los comercios están obligados
a aceptarlo como método de pago
y ya sé lo que estáis pensando muchos
sobre todo los que seáis fans de las
cripto divisas viva el presidente del
salvador vivan allí bukele hagamos las
maletas y vayámonos a vivir a este país
porque es la capital el paraíso el oasis
de las cripto divisas es más y más este
vídeo es de venezuela o argentina
seguramente os suene a música celestial
si hay un problema común en casi todos
los países de latinoamérica ese es
precisamente la divisa sin embargo el
salvador es ajeno a todos estos
problemas porque pues precisamente
porque ahora mismo ya utilizan el dólar
estadounidense
y precisamente esa es la pregunta de
este vídeo que ha movido a nagy bukele a
declarar el bitcoin como moneda de curso
legal en el salvador de verdad se va a
convertir el salvador en el paraíso de
las cripto divisas o hay tal vez alguna
trampa algún caballo de troya en esta
ley con la que se pondrá en marcha esta
decisión hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
hablar de la otra cara de internet la
otra cara de la seguridad en internet
tanto si os gustan escritos como si
queréis hacer cualquier otro pago con
tarjeta por internet tenéis que tener
mucho cuidado hay un montón de hackers
por ahí deseando hacerse con vuestra
información privada y robar
[Música]
y os preguntaréis como podéis protegeros
de los hackers pues una forma muy buena
de hacerlo es utilizando una vpn para
navegar por internet una vpn como surf
shark tours arc es una vpn fantástica la
favorita de visual política no solo nos
protege de hackers bots de propaganda y
virus sino que además permite que
podamos entrar en cualquier sitio de
internet sin encontrarnos con estos
mensajes de esta página está bloqueada
en tu país sabemos que puedes visitar
cualquier sitio web de forma segura
además usar tiene una herramienta que se
llama clean web que bloquea todos esos
popups de propaganda por donde se cuela
en un montón de bots y cookies que
francamente no queremos tener en nuestro
ordenador por si todo esto fuera poco
con una misma cuenta de surf shark
podrás registrar todos los dispositivos
que quieras quieres navegar con
seguridad desde tu smart tv o desde tu
teléfono móvil o desde tu ordenador pues
lo puedes hacer todo con una única
cuenta de surf shark vp
y como siempre tenemos un descuento de
lujo para todos vosotros que seguís
visual polític básicamente si utilizáis
el código político terminado
tendréis un 83% de descuento más tres
meses extra totalmente gratuitos tenéis
toda la información en los links de la
descripción no esperéis más y
descargados ya la aplicación y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
servit coin cuál es la principal
diferencia entre una cripto divisa y el
dinero normal que no era normal lo que
también llamamos dinero fiat se crea
desde los bancos centrales por ejemplo
la reserva federal de eeuu o el banco
central europeo son quienes controlan la
oferta monetaria de dólares o de euros
respectivamente
sin embargo tanto bitcoin como la
mayoría de las cripto divisas tienen una
historia totalmente distinta el bit que
fue creado en el año 2009 por satoshi
nakamoto un seudónimo que esconde la
identidad real de su creador ni siquiera
sabemos quién es este buen señor o
señora y el bitcoin se basa en la
tecnología block chain y os preguntaréis
cómo funciona esta tecnología pues eso
es tema para otro vídeo porque lo
importante en este vídeo es que el
bitcoin es una divisa donde no hacen
falta bancos comerciales ni estados que
los regulen
y precisamente esta es una de las cosas
más importantes del bitcoin que no está
bajo la supervisión de ningún estado o
gobierno es decir que no hay nadie que
controle la oferta de bitcoins
teóricamente habrá un número limitado de
bitcoins en la economía mundial
concretamente 21 millones de bitcoins
cuando se llegue a esa cifra ya no habrá
ningún bitcoin más y diréis qué ventaja
tiene esto pues en principio impediría
que llegara el gobernante de turno y se
dedicará a manipular la oferta de dinero
así que se supone que esto debería
servir para darle estabilidad a su valor
como moneda desde luego esta es la
teoría porque la realidad es este 19 de
mayo de 2021 bitcoin azota a los
inversores con caídas y repuntes del 30
por ciento en el mismo día exacto la
realidad es que el bitcoin fluctúa más
que la báscula de russell crowe qué
significa todo esto pues que casi nadie
lo utiliza como método de pago pero
esperad un momento porque no sólo es que
su valor sea especialmente inestable
algo que no se suele mencionar es que el
bitcoin es también especialmente lento
mirad esta gráfica donde veis la
comparación entre la capacidad de
procesar transacciones que ofrece visas
la compañía de tarjetas
y otras cripta divisas incluida bitcoin
esto significa que en tres horas visa
tiene la capacidad de procesar las
mismas operaciones que bitcoin en un año
entero y por supuesto que eviten puede
mejorar pero a día de hoy la realidad es
ésta así que si vives en eeuu con la
unión europea parece buena idea seguir
funcionando con los dólares o los euros
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
los de visual política están totalmente
en contra de las cripto divisas verdad
pues no exactamente es más hay un lugar
del mundo donde las cripto divisas si
pueden tener mucho interés
hablamos de latinoamérica digámoslo
claro hablar de hiperinflación es hablar
de latinoamérica por poner un ejemplo
venezuela ha llegado a tener inflación
es de más del 100 mil por ciento pero no
es el único país que ha sufrido de
hiperinflación tanto brasil como
nicaragua también tuvieron casos de
hiperinflación hace unas pocas décadas y
qué me decís de argentina adventure 19
de mayo de 2021 la inflación cercana al
50 por ciento coloca argentina en un
camino en el que antes fracasó y diréis
pero porque latinoamérica tiene
tantísima hiperinflación la principal
razón es que los bancos centrales
manipulan la ddi
pronto he dicho de una forma más común
que le dan a la máquina de imprimir
billetes como si no hubiera mañana esto
provoca que sus divisas valgan menos que
los billetes del monopoly así que la
idea de utilizar una divisa que no está
controlada por ningún gobierno ningún
banco central para muchos suena como
música celestial el 22 de junio de 2021
a medida que la economía de venezuela
retrocede en la script o divisas llenan
los agujeros como os podéis imaginar es
lógico que en venezuela utilicen
cualquier cosa antes que el bolívar la
pregunta es por qué querían utilizar
bitcoin en el salvador a fin de cuentas
en este país utilizan el dólar como
moneda oficial es decir que no tienen
grandes problemas de inflación entonces
porque han decidido apostar tanto por el
bitcoin pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la gran idea bukele el salvador tiene un
presidente millenials ya sabéis que
nadie bukele es la nueva rockstar de la
política de latinoamérica aunque muchos
piensan que también es un aspirante a
tirano pero de eso hablamos más en
profundidad en otro vídeo que os dejo en
la descripción acierto es quien el
programa de la jeep buque lee cuando se
presentaban las elecciones no decían
nada del beat que sin embargo de repente
era una conferencia sobre bitcoin
celebrada en miami se emitió por
sorpresa para todos este vídeo del
presidente buque
la semana que viene enviaré al congreso
un proyecto de ley que convertirá
bitcoin en una moneda de curso legal en
el salvador a corto plazo esto generará
empleos y ayudará a brindar inclusión
financiera a miles de personas fuera de
la economía formal como os podéis
imaginar después de este vídeo ya no se
hablaba de otra cosa en el salvador ni
en muchos otros países todo eran dudas
porque el único anuncio oficial fue este
vídeo en inglés emitido en miami nadie
explicaba nada en el salvador y apenas
tres días después el gobierno presentó
la ley
bitcoin que fue aprobada en cuestión de
horas por el parlamento y hacen todos
porque hablamos de una ley que tiene 16
artículos
más que cualquier guión de visual
política ocupa 4 veces más
[Música]
en estos 16 artículos no se entra en
muchos detalles pero sí que hay cosas
interesantes por ejemplo esta ley dice
que se podrán pagar impuestos con
bitcoin y no en esto no van a ser
pioneros los salvadoreños porque desde
hace meses el cantón suizo de zug acepta
el pago de impuestos tanto con bitcoin
como con héctor aún así no deja de ser
llamativo pero si hay un punto polémico
en esta ley bitcoin es el artículo 7
mira todo agente económico deberá
aceptar bitcoin como forma de pago
cuando así les sea ofrecido por quien
adquiera un bien o servicio artículo 7
de la ley bitcoin según este artículo
parece evidente que se obligará a los
salvadoreños a aceptar bitcoin quieran o
no en un primer momento así lo pareció
confirmar el propio ebook el 9 de junio
de 2021
bukele si hay una señora que vende fruta
en el mercado está obligada a recibir el
pago en bitcoin el problema está cuando
una vez aprobada la ley bitcoin justo
dos semanas después te pones a dar
explicaciones os acordáis de los
hermanos marx y la primera parte de la
parte contratante de la segunda primera
parte
bueno pues bukele podemos decir que les
he hecho un gran homenaje
sería que todos están obligados a
aceptar el vídeo de como forma de pago y
por lo tanto recibir el bit con pero no
es así que los agentes económicos es
decir los comercios están obligados a
aceptar bitcoin pero no a recibirlo el
artículo 8 también es muy interesante
porque pues porque dice que podrá
superar en bitcoin con goles privados
que el estado proveerá alternativas que
permitan realizar transacciones en
bitcoin y quiere decir esto pues ni más
ni menos que buque le ha creado el world
del gobierno para operar con bitcoins se
llamará chivo y esto ya empieza a
chirriar un poco incluso a los fans de
las cripto divisas porque una de las
premisas de bitcoin es que es algo
descentralizado es decir algo
completamente fuera del alcance de los
gobiernos eso por no hablar de otro
asunto que tampoco inspira mucha
confianza si hay algo que llegó a abu
que le arrasar en las elecciones es que
se presentó ante la gente como un
paladín de la transparencia y la lucha
contra la corrupción un adalid con el
que olvidar todos los escándalos de los
gobiernos del fmln o arena sin embargo
mis queridos amigos de visual política
lo que rodea al colectivo recuerdo
demasiado a las malas prácticas 30 de
junio de 2021 buque limita al fmln y
adjudica proyecto bitcoin de forma
directa habéis oído bien de forma
directa es decir sin concurso público ni
citación ni nada de nada buque le ha
adjudicado el desarrollo del google el
chivo a una empresa estadounidense que
se llama strike y diréis como lo ha
decidido por democracia digital es decir
a dedo pero esperad un momento porque
esta ley bitcoin esconde todavía alguna
trampa y aquí es donde viene el caballo
de troya después de lo que vamos a ver
será el momento en el que vosotros los
fans del víctor y respondáis a la gran
pregunta que es de verdad seríais al
salvador para poder vivir nuestro día a
día haciendo uso de vuestra cripto
divisa favorita atentos a la pantalla
[Música]
la letra pequeña de la ley bitcoin que
no sabéis cuál es la principal fuente de
ingresos del salvador pues si las
remesas una cuarta parte de los
salvadoreños es decir dos millones de
personas viven en el extranjero la mayor
parte de ellos en eeuu pues bien todos
estos salvadoreños envían dinero a sus
familias de qué cantidades hablamos pues
se estima que hablamos ni más ni menos
que de seis mil millones de dólares cada
año unas cifras equivalentes al 20 por
ciento del pib del salvador el país
ingresa lo mismo por esta vía que por
sus exportaciones los salvadoreños que
han emigrado utilizan los giros postales
para enviar estas cantidades a sus
familias hablamos de empresas como
western union o moneygram entre otros
os podéis imaginar estas compañías no lo
hacen gratis y cobran comisiones la
cuestión según asegura el presidente
bucl es que los ciudadanos salvadoreños
se beneficiarían si utilizaran bitcoins
en lugar de dólares para hacer las
remesas porque pues porque sería más
barato el problema el problema es que
los datos se empeñan en llevarle la
contraria
curiosamente el salvador tiene una de
las comisiones para remesas más bajas
del mundo para que os hagáis una idea la
media en latinoamérica es del 5,6 por
ciento en el salvador es del 2 85 por
ciento e dados con este número 2,85 por
ciento y diréis cuánto cuesta cambiar de
dólares a víctor pues la empresa que más
cajeros de bitcoin tiene en el país se
llama hacen a esta empresa cobra una
comisión atentos del 5%
[Música]
y ahora os preguntaréis entonces por qué
tanto interés en utilizar el víctor pues
aquí viene una posible explicación el
gobierno de el salvador no tiene ningún
control sobre las remesas y sabe cuántas
llegan y por supuesto las puede poner
impuestos sin embargo y si las remesas
llegarán en bitcoin por ejemplo imagina
que mandamos bitcoin a alguien que vive
en el salvador que tiene el cual es del
gobierno el wall chivo dicho de otra
forma el gobierno podría colocar la
comisión la tasa de conversión que le
viniera en gana pero ya sé lo que estáis
pensando y si utilizamos otro boleto que
no sea del gobierno y aquí aquí es donde
llega la letra pequeña de la ley y las
cosas no están claras 21 de junio de
2021 el salvador fondos para cambiar el
bitcoin a dólar serían insuficientes
acudamos de nuevo a la ley bitcoin su
artículo 14 dice que el estado
garantizará la convertibilidad
automática e instantánea de bitcoin a
dólar siempre y cuando utilice su wall
es decir el wall & chivo pero esperad un
momento porque aquí hay más aquí llega
el artículo 9 de la ley y diréis que
dice ese artículo pues habla de las
limitaciones
las alternativas de conversión
automática dicho de otra forma el
gobierno podría prohibir utilizar otro
bullet que no fuese el tema gobierno
y si tenéis toda la razón muchas de
estas limitaciones todavía están por
fijar en un reglamento que todavía no se
ha aprobado y muchos os preguntaréis
pero por qué querrían limitar los goles
que se utilizan pues veréis el gobierno
ha creado un fondo de 150 millones de
dólares para garantizar la conversión de
bitcoin a dólar el problema es qué
pasaría si todo el mundo se lanzara a
cambiar débito y nadal a qué pasaría si
ese fondo se agotará pues lo cierto es
que nadie lo sabe y booking le parece
demasiado ocupado con cosas propias 10
de junio de 2021 nagy bukele presidente
del salvador se ponemos láser en twitter
para apoyar el bitcoin a la vez nadie
porque le ha disparado el gasto público
sin subir los impuestos el país necesita
dólares para pagar su endeudamiento y
estos dólares les pueden llegar de las
remesas mientras sus ciudadanos reciben
beatles la papeleta para los
salvadoreños tampoco creáis que sencilla
en resumen si no usas el web del
gobierno te comerás el riesgo de tener
bitcoin porque ya conocéis su
volatilidad así que de partida tienes un
incentivo muy gordo para utilizar el
boleto de viaje
[Música]
y claro si utilizas ese wall en el wall
el chivo habrá que estar atento al
reglamento que fije las limitaciones del
wall porque una vez acabado en los
dólares del fideicomiso podría darse una
situación de corralito en la que esté
limitado el cambiado las dicho de otra
forma que lo único que te queden son los
bitcoin con los que podrás operar en el
salvador pero que no te van a ser muy
útiles fuera del país
además pensad que bucle tiene entre
manos otro problema muy urgente que
resolver
10 de marzo de 2021 la deuda del
salvador podría alcanzar el 100% de su
pib según el icefi la deuda del país
supone ya más del 90 por ciento del pib
dicho de otra forma porque no iban a
colocar una tasa para poder sacar tajada
de las remesas eso por no hablar de que
si ahora los salvadoreños pagarán sus
impuestos con bitcoin el fideicomiso de
dólares se va a convertir en bitcoins
vamos que de repente el estado
salvadoreño va a verse con un montón de
bitcoins en su poder con todo lo que eso
implica es decir la decisión de boo que
le puede convertirse en todo un pelotazo
si el bitcoin de repente se revaloriza
pero puede pasar todo lo contrario si el
bitcoin se hunde en este caso la gran
pregunta es cómo se las apañará entonces
alza
para afrontar su deuda externa y mucho
me temo que terminaremos hablando de eso
en los próximos meses pero ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros veis que la
decisión de nagy bukele es un acierto o
es demasiado arriesgada gustaría que
vuestro país también convirtiera el
bitcoin en moneda de curso legal podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a este canal darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
bien